another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation showing monty  python episodes to scp-239 was not a  wise decision please never try this with  any other reality warping scp seriously  dr bright the witch child is a reality  warper so powerful we need to keep her  in a comatose state to stop her from  permanently reformatting our universe do  you really think it's a good idea to  show her flying circus or the holy grail  if we find that by sheer coincidence we  later need to contain an anomaly that  shares a remarkable resemblance to the  black beast of  we know exactly who is responsible and  we will not take this indiscretion  lightly we might even make you sit on  the comfy chair